hello everybody i'm josh welch president
of film independent and welcome to a
very special edition of film independent
presents
where we get to speak with the
filmmakers behind promising young women
before we get started a couple quick
thank yous for me
uh first of all thank you to the
hollywood foreign press association the
lead funder for film independent
presents
we're so appreciative to you for your
year-round support of truly
thank you uh and then secondly i want to
thank our screening partner vision media
the platform that we use for film
independent presents
you guys are the best um so so happy to
be working with you
um i just want to thank focus features
for today
um and with that it is my enormous
pleasure to
welcome the writer and director of
promising young woman
emerald fennell and the star of this
remarkable film carrie mulligan um thank
you both for being here to talk about
the film
thank you for having us um so
it what an incredible film i mean i'll
just start with
let me just do my my gushing at the
beginning i love the film so much
you know i went into it cold i did not
go to sundance last year so i didn't get
a chance to see it there
and i heard great things about it but i
really sort of tuned out any critical
response to it so i saw it cold and i
just
i mean it blew me away on so many levels
um
the genre elements the the style of the
film
carries performance the writing i mean
the the
it's a high wire act this film and
uh and it's your i know you've worked in
film for quite a while emerald as a as
an actor and as a writer
um but this was your first feature
correct yes
i mean unbelievable regardless of how
many features
you already made but as your first
feature it's it's
really truly remarkable um could you
talk a bit about sort of the genesis of
the project when the idea first came to
you and
and how how it evolved from there
yeah absolutely i think well i first
started sort of thinking about it and
kind of i guess i was pitching it by
spring kind of 2017 so maybe a couple of
years before that and
i guess um i thought a lot
about the culture that i grew up in the
the use of alcohol
in kind of hookup culture the sort of
things that had just been
completely normalized that were actually
incredibly abusive sort of things that
were jokes in
movies and tv shows um that really
weren't funny so
um and what usually happens for me is a
scene it will
start with a scene and so uh the scene
that kind of this
started from was just a drunk girl lying
on a bed
if somebody undresses her kind of
drunkenly saying what are you doing and
then
sitting up staying called sober and
saying
what are you doing and that i think that
moment i sort of thought okay
i think i know what this movie is about
and i think i have an idea of who this
woman is
and so from that you you
you didn't have the story mapped out at
that point from that point on then you
just went into writing the script and
so no i um then i uh
so the way i write which is i suppose
sort of
maybe slightly different is that i don't
write anything down really until it's
finished
completely finished in my head so it
usually takes me a couple of years to
finish it completely and then i'll write
it down um
and so for me i was very lucky because i
pitched it to lucky chap
um who were just amazing and i just
pitched them the cold open so
that really culminating in that scene
and they bought it
with no just off that so then
when i handed the movie into them
whenever it was kind of eight months
later i think
um they yeah they were kind of reading
it pretty cool too
wow and uh and then when at what point
did you get the script to carry
i suppose we you know we did the kind of
usual things we went
film nation came on board and then uh
we went to kerry um
once yeah i suppose for a few months
later
um i'm just incredibly lucky that she
said yes harry what was your
rea i'm curious if you'd known emerald
before
i forgive me i don't know if you'd
worked together previous to this
but what was your knowledge of her and
what was your reaction to the script
when you first read it
well we we had worked before but neither
of us remembered that until we were
about
halfway through our shoot um because
we'd actually worked when we were both
19 19 years old we'd worked on an
episode of trial and retribution
sims of the father on television where
we i'd paid a murder victim and emerald
played my
nasty friend um but we couldn't remember
we didn't
have no recollection of that um so we we
had and
you know our paths had crossed in one
sense in that you know
emerald um was a was an assistant to my
agent to belfridge
um for a little bit when we were sort of
you know just left school
and then so i and i and our friend our
mutual friend emma freud um
sort of introduced us at her house
um knowing that i think emerald had the
script um
sort of a little bit of a setup but we
didn't talk about it emerald was on her
way to the killing eve wrap party
and i remember thinking she was very
cool and i wanted to be her best friend
um but i you know there was no real talk
about the work and then it was after
christmas sort of a month or so later
that i got the script and
and so um yeah i just i
was blown away by it um like everyone
was who read it
um and i wanted to meet emerald as soon
as i could
properly now knowing that there was this
possibility of a job
and and um knowing that you know like it
gets
coffee a couple days later and in the
interim she sent me this incredible
spotify playlist
uh with you know boys charlie xcx and
britney spears
toxic in two different forms and stars
are blind
and you know the wagner and you know all
of the songs that you hear in the film
pretty much
um so i was sort of starting to get a
sense of
the tone of this thing and i was just so
excited so
picking up on that i actually wanted to
ask you emerald about the music
i mean music and tone right the i mean
the
music cues throughout the film are so
fantastic
um and it's the britney spear scene in
the pharmacy is incredible
in fact that whole montage of the the
heteronormative montage where the pink
and the blue and the
the dancing and everything was an
incredible sequence but um could you
talk a bit about music
were you thinking about those music cues
when you were writing uh in your head
before even putting it on paper
yeah so it's so so the
for me the playlist that i sent carrie
was the playlist that i
so i just sit and listen a thousand
billion times
as i go through it all in my head so
that it's sort of it's usually
really very much part of the fabric of
the thing as i'm writing it and then
and in the script there are i think
probably four or five music cues
um something wonderful was in there and
toxic and and paris hilton stars blind
so
um yeah it's just hugely important to me
i think it's
just um does so much
sets so much of the tone and it was
really specifically important for this
film because
i think um music look that
the music in this movie is the kind of
music that's often not treated very
seriously
in the way that i think you know
manicure aren't taken very seriously and
clothes aren't taken very seriously
things that i think maybe traditionally
young women like
are often sort of disparaged or thought
of as not being serious it was very
important
really from the get-go that this felt
like
um a woman's world and that it had
all of the things i suppose from my life
and so many women's lives that
feels profoundly serious and moving um
even though it might not uh be
ideal culturally perceived that way
one of the most striking things to me
about the film is how you combine
there's like the film is very stylized
and it has like i mean i don't want to
mischaracterize it but to me it had
like there was something fun about the
look of the film and the feel of it and
the tone and the music
and the pacing and right it but then it
it combines with this
emotionally resonant
story i mean and it's testament carried
to your performance
but also to the film as a whole where
you you're able to juggle
the the veneer of the film or the style
of the film with this like
emotional through line that is just
relentless and devastating
and it's i don't know it's so unusual to
see those combined in that way
um there's not a question lurking i
wish i'd framed that as a question but
um
i mean was that something that you tried
to articulate to
to your cast and crew when you started
making how did you get everyone to
understand that you were all making the
same movie and it had this tone
and style i think well it was partly
you know doing doing as it did with
kerry which was sent to sort of
relentlessly detailed
kind of thousand page mood board and
playlists and
all of this sort of thing um but i think
the movies that i love
are sort of somewhat allegorical at
least
or certainly they at least feel like
movies they feel kind of considered
and um and it particularly felt
real that cassie who is such a
meticulous person
so expert at hiding in plain sight so
expert of kind of using her femininity
to disguise you know deep rage and grief
so it felt like it needed to look and
sound like
her film which was that it was um yeah
innocuous seemingly um
uh soft and inviting and pleasurable and
then
maybe something more complicated but
really
the whole thing hinges on carrie's
unbelievably beautiful
and grounded performance you know we
were able to kind of
create this world around her because
really you're just following cassie and
everything around her is just a
reflection of how she feels
um yeah and so i think really it's so
it's so much down to kerry
kerry could you talk about when you came
onto the film like how did you prepare
for the role
or what what sort of process did you go
through to find the character
um and bring it to life in the way you
did
yeah i mean it was really um
basically just with emerald you know um
it wasn't a sort of you know that
there's
all of this stuff so much of what
happens in our film is just all too
familiar
in a way so it wasn't sort of one of
those things where you needed to go off
and sort of learn how to ride a horse or
speak russian you know there was
something about this that just felt so
close to home
um in so many ways and i think it was
just about sort of
emerald and i being on exactly the same
page in terms of
what you know who cassie was before you
know really what
who was she before this happened who was
nina um
what was their relationship and what is
it that she's lost
and who is it this that she's doing this
on behalf of
um you know because i think she tells
herself that this is a
sort of this is for her friend but i
think it's you know and she
she wants to you know she wants people
to ask for forgiveness but you know
she's
she's really looking for forgiveness
herself she feels
responsible um and and and she
sort of can't let it go so emerald and i
just had loads of conversations about
what that friendship is you know when
you're growing up together and you
have all the same references and you
love all the same things and you know
that person better than anyone in the
world
um and just tried to sort of establish a
really
clear story in our minds um most of
which is not
ever talked about in the film but it
gave us a reference point for sort of
pretty much every scene
um and yeah that was it really we just
you know
it was one of the relationships with the
director that i've had that's so
so i had a similar relationship with
steve mcqueen on shane
where you know we talked constantly
about sissy's life
um and you know so it got to set that we
there was just a shorthand of when we
were sort of actually doing the takes
and that's what emerald and i had
just we'd sort of we were in cahoots on
the whole thing
[Music]
um listening to you talk i i found
myself thinking back on the scene
uh with your friends
with molly shannon out on the porch
where clearly clearly you are there for
some form of self-forgiveness
i mean that was a scene that i just
thought was so powerful when she walks
away and goes in the house like
just your isolation in that moment was
really really came through powerfully
um yeah i mean i think it was you know
i i can't i still can't get over how
incredible
every single person who came in and
played one scene or two
scenes in this film was because you know
we did have the most astonishing cast
who were all just drawn there by
emerald's writing
and how exceptional her writing was um
but molly shannon was with us for like
three hours and she came
and she you know she just did that she
just gave that one
you know and as if she'd you know
studied this character her whole life
she just you know
knew knew it in and out and you know
emotionally just
just delivered on the first take and you
know when you've got people like that to
work with it just
you know it's an embarrassment of riches
really every every single
person who came in to work on this yeah
so
and in terms of casting i also wanted to
bring up the men in the film
or many of the men i mean incredible
casting of
horrible men and horrible men who don't
seem horrible at first glance and
you know it's i mean obviously it's what
the film is about is kind of
uh but there were so many uh
moments where i mean one of my favorite
moments is outside the nightclub
when the guy in the fedora says i forget
his exact climb he's like
why do you guys always have to ruin
everything it's so
classic right i mean that was just yeah
yes you capture male entitlement and
toxic
masculinity very like clearly and
powerfully and also where it's
like they're real characters and and i
mean at the the fra
the i was gonna say frat party the
bachelor party at the end
i mean that gathering of men was to me
like
so familiar and believable like i know
those guys
and i know the offhand way of
communicating
and the things that can happen um and
also the net i mean you have a number of
people say oh we were just kids i think
even bo burnham says that right it's
like
the excuses that people make for their
behavior
it's like absolutely and i think the
excuses are
culture makes for everyone's behavior
that's the
the stuff that is so difficult in this
movie is that it is
oh it certainly was when i was growing
up i think less so but still
unfortunately completely commonplace
you know when you think of comedy movies
really like huge mainstream comedy
movies
the last 10 15 years and and network tv
shows
girls waking up not knowing who the guy
next to them is and having a walk of
shame home
you know played for laughs um you know
guys wanting to lose their virginity by
any means necessary no matter
how much trickery is involved um
you know and drunk hookups that turn out
to be sort of big romances
like this is just it was just it's so
much the fabric
of all of our lives um and
such a huge part and a sort of really
sinister horrible part of
the kind of um hookup culture i guess
um it was really important that from the
get-go
was saying like nobody in this movie
thinks they're a bad
person not the women or men they really
really
have never thought about it because
you know but if they were to they would
um kind of come up short i think that
was the
thing for me it was it was just if if
something isn't bad
then why do you feel bad why do you feel
guilty if somebody points it out that's
you know and so of course it's about
people not being
who they seem cassie isn't what she
seems the film isn't really what it
seems and
and the kind of incidents that we're
talking about in this film
are often done by popular men
handsome men men who absolutely identify
as good who would be
mortified to ever have anything
kind of like this next to their name
it's just they haven't thought about it
because they haven't been made to
and this is why it's so uncomfortable
and frightening
yeah i thought the wedding at the end
was so
an incredible choice for the wedding
like the woman officiating and the kind
of the hippie vibe
and then when the groom says to his the
woman that he's marrying that she's
his moral conscience i mean it's just
like
unbelievable you know it's yeah but it
is because it is those people and and
that thing of like
it says it said to him
so often it's not your fault right
that's what everyone hears it's not your
fault
you know and wouldn't you rather believe
it wasn't your fault
wouldn't you rather believe you're a
good person like who wants to be the
person on the other side of the door
when cassie comes knocking
nobody does so that's it's
you know it's sort of i think more
broadly about
how we all are complicit in things
you know knowingly or unknowingly
i i also love how cassie goes after
not just the guys who are directly
involved but anyone involved in what
happened so going to the lawyer
going to the dean of the school all you
know whether male
or female she's calling everyone out i
thought the scene with is that the dean
where's connie britton plays the dean i
mean she that was
incredible because she didn't simply
didn't remember this
incredible moment in other people's
lives
i mean carrie when you say oh she called
you
like she filed a report with you you
know it's just the blank look on her
face was
was amazing um but carrie i want to ask
like
in your performance it i felt like
there's this
quiet simmering rage and grief
under the surface but on the surface
you're playing all these other things
and it's
the grief and rage are always there
especially as the movie progresses
i mean to the viewer but how did you
it's just i
how did you how did you do that how did
you go about
sort of modulating like what you're
conveying
openly and what you want to reserve
under the surface
yeah i think a lot of that was um
our communication emerald and i because
you know there wasn't really
we had sort of two days where various
actors who were available came in and we
read the lines together but there was no
sort of rehearsal
um so some actors we were just meeting
on the day
um and we hadn't kind of made a bunch of
decisions really about
anything we had our store we knew you
know we we had some
facts and we had we'd had lots of
conversations but there was no
sort of we hadn't made any rehearsed or
made any kind of performance choices so
it was really like
trying things in the moment um
and i felt very very comfortable
just allowing emerald to steer the ship
and she would ask for one thing and i
would do that and then we'd try
something else and
you know um she'd push me to do
something and i'd
resist and then do it and then i'd do
the opposite in the next take
so i felt like you know there was a real
uh i felt you know emerald had the
bird's eye view
um so in that sense it was just a lot of
playing
um and i think you know the fact that we
had this and in a way actually it was
what i found helpful was that no one
else knew our story no one else knew
really
anything about nina or what happened you
know in that room it was our
emerald and i were the only ones who you
know had that information basically
um so it was uh
i don't know it felt like a sort of
secret um and i think it
that's how it felt in the playing of it
um
yeah emerald could you talk
a bit about um
just the the the look of the film the
the stylistic elements that you wanted
to weave in the genre thriller elements
like it works very well just on that
level it's like
i mean there were moments of the film
that were incredibly painful to watch
um especially towards the end i mean uh
but on another level the film is
incredibly
fun and enjoyable like as a piece of
cinema
i feel like that i do feel like there's
one point of commonality between this
film and your work on killing eve where
killing eve as a show also has that
duality of like
this is an incredibly fun pulpy watch
but it's also dealing with
like really serious themes and issues
and the way you woke those
i'm just as a first-time director just
as a director on this film
how did you go about establishing those
the genre elements the production design
the
look and the feel of it well
i think it was it was partly um
setting out that stall quite early on so
you know being
sending out this sort of huge bible of
references and um of mood boards and
and all of this sort of stuff and being
very very specific about things like
cassie's costume
and the rooms that she's in and i think
more than anything you've got to be led
by
the lead your protagonist and the film
really needs to be a reflection of who
they are
and and so
she is a person who is kind of
preoccupied with detail preoccupied with
presentation
we talked a lot me and curry about sort
of addicts
and self-farmers people who are in in
those cycles who are
um you know using something in order to
keep
everything else kind of underneath and
you see this with her particularly in
the early
in the early scenes where she's kind of
using these his nighttime
kind of activities to to stop doing the
thing that she eventually does which was
go after the
more personal things but so that's all
to say that i think the film
itself needed to feel like her film it
needed to feel kind of
static stuck in stuck in a specific time
and a place and and and formal almost
she's very reserved
as a person say she's controlled super
controlled so it needed to
that the film needed to express all of
that
about who she was but also you know that
it was
like she is kind of a trap a beautiful
soft pink trap the thing i
suppose that women are traditionally
frightening for that they look like
sugar and spice and all things nice and
they might not be they might be
terrifying sort of evil witches or you
know whatever it is
traditionally women have been accused of
so i think yeah it was it was really
it was just about setting
setting the world making the world her
world i suppose
and as for the genre stuff it just it
sort of
for me dark comedy is really where i'm
most comfortable
and so everything really has that vein
of kind of
you know being aware of the genre and
what the tropes of
the revenge thriller are and and the
story beats and really just using those
to actually
kind of subvert the audience expectation
and and um and yeah and then
spending the rest of the time just
holding
cassie i guess
[Music]
i had a specific question about um
cassie's house and her bedroom and the
living room the production design of her
house
was bonkers i loved it but it was so
formal and i was like who is this family
living this way can you talk about how
you
came up with her home
yeah well i think it's it's probably the
most
um perfect sort of symbol of
cassie's life really is that you can see
firstly where she gets her eye from i
think
um and her fondness for sort of pastels
but it really
for me i think it needed to feel like a
place that was kind of out of time
that was sort of stuck in a moment maybe
the sort of
you know 90s when cassie was a child it
felt very much
like a place that where
you know her mother had put all of the
love that she could no longer put
into her daughter so it was just you
know it could talk about a hat on a hat
it was
you know cherubs on crystals on dog
portraits on pink shea's longs it was
it's stiflingly feminine it's stiflingly
um still quiet everything looked
beautiful i you know i think it's
baroque
it's overwatch it's um but there's
plastic on the tablecloth so you can't
make it dirty for everything to look
specific and sadly lots of scenes with
jennifer
that in the end we just couldn't use
because it just made the film too long
but amazing scenes of jennifer
and she's always gluing shells onto
things
you know she's always gluing and it's
just again it just seemed like the
perfect
metaphor for like everything's fine as
long as i glue enough shells you could
feel if you always would
lose shells on cassie you know make it
better
and it just seemed like a very feminine
thing you know make it better put
lipstick on it
make it pretty um so one story beat that
i was not
really was powerful and and
to me i was surprised by is towards the
end so people watching this conversation
have
seen the film so no spoilers here but at
the end with what happens that
to cassie at the at the bachelor party i
mean
was oh my god it was a horrifying scene
i mean you held that shot for so long
when he's kneeling over her with the
pillow
that was just agonizing to watch um
and i really didn't know how it was
going to end because it just kept going
and i was like oh maybe she's not going
to die
but when did that come to you in the in
the writing process
i'm assuming you didn't have that at the
beginning like
no no no but i think the moment it
became apparent that she was going to go
to the cabin um
you know as you say that you you often
see strippers in movies
you rarely see what they see and feel
what they feel
and it needed to feel her walking into
that cabin
like a wall of like pulsating
testosterone and you know
with the when she starts stripping it's
important that we
turned away and used the phantom to kind
of pick them up in all their detail and
it was
you know erections straining against
their chinos and teeth
and fingernails it was that kind of
animal
thing that is very you know
very frightening and i think
that is all to sort of say that that's
why women don't use weapons and it's why
that i think um traditional revenge
movies
that don't address they don't really
address this stuff which is the reason
that cassie doesn't
bring a weapon is that she knows she
can't win i mean
you can't win so it was important
it was important not to have the sort of
empty
catharsis which would only have been
possible if i'd said
well as long as you plan it diligently
enough
and you bring a scalpel
you'll you can win because it's just
simply not true statistically it's not
true if you look at carey
and you look at chris there's just no
contest
so it kind of felt like it had to be
honest there and then i knew that if it
was the first time we saw violence in
this movie that people assumed was going
to be very violent
it needed to be real so it's all
amazing kerry and chris and the one shot
is as long as it takes to suffocate
someone so it was two and a half minutes
and it needed to feel like he was
frightened
and she was frightened as well and it
shocked both of them because i don't
think she
you know she knew it might happen she
made a contingency plan because she's
not
an idiot but i don't think she wanted it
to happen so
yeah it just honestly felt like
the only the only outcome that i felt
was
honest um and
you know and of course we do expect her
to sit back up and we want her to
but yeah that this stuff isn't fair
i do have her in a way you know you
don't have her sit back
up but she still has agency after her
death because she's
yeah put these things in place i'd say
that was incredibly
satisfying and a relief to have her have
that moment
i mean yeah i think i've been
i think we all felt i certainly thought
it would have been much too
relentless um and also i i just
for somebody is meticulous at her
there's no way it wouldn't have crossed
her mind
that she was gonna do something super
dangerous going there
so yeah i feel like
we might yeah i want gary to talk i'm
talking so much i'm sorry
we have a lot of questions here from the
audience so let me uh
one question right off the top was it as
cathartic for you making this movie as
it was for us watching
carrie 100 yes
i thought you're going to say was it as
cathartic for you smashing up the car as
it was for us watching because that
genuinely was really cathartic that was
a great day
uh next question this goes back to what
we were just talking about emerald on
the ending someone
named will asks was there any pushback
on the ending
were multiple ones written i have to say
i was not expecting it and wasn't sure
how i felt but after sitting with it it
felt
100 right bravo oh thank you
um there were there was no
other there was no other ending um
and i was very very lucky in that lucky
chap
kind of when they first got the script
really understood
um why and what it was and it kind of in
a way it
it was incredibly useful having that
ending because
the people who understood and loved it
really really loved it and the people
who didn't like it
like i completely understood why they
didn't but it made it very easy for us
to then
go on to choose our studio who ended up
being film nation and
um and then our distributor focus who
you know both of them were in it
i think for it as a whole
um and i think everyone understood that
for the because of course i think we can
all imagine what the other ending would
be
but that would have made it the revenge
movie i think that it
it was i suppose trying
not to be it was trying to keep away
from that sort of
slightly empty um
satisfaction maybe um
so another question um this we spoke a
bit about the music but uh somebody
jake asks for emerald the music
brilliantly subverted many of my
expectations in the film
what advice would you give to a
filmmaker who wants the soundtrack to
subvert audience expectations
god that's such a good question i think
you think it really helps just
choosing stuff you love and not i think
i think coolness and music are really
coolness is a kind of very deadening
concept when it comes to music and
something that's so
seems to be so like oppressive so for me
it was definitely about really being led
by what i
what i in my gut love and what makes me
feel something
and whether that's like something from a
musical or brittany or
paris hilton you know um but in terms of
being subversive it just depends
where you where you want to use it if
you can find lyrics that
you know that will that when listened to
a second time like something wonderful
which is a you know a love song about a
man who's
horrible basically and who needs to be
forgiven constantly
you know that's that's a real gimme i
think
okay um here's one this is a sort of a
combination comment and question
from andrew i love this movie and
cheered at the cut to black
the timing with just call me angel was
killer and speaking of killer
was there any was there ever any talk of
cassie killing these guys she picks up
from the bar
or was psychologically screwing with
them always more
effective in her journey emerald
congrats on one hell of a debut
and carrie congratulations on your
performance
um well again i think it's it's
um
what is more frightening i would sort of
ask that i would like maybe
ask the question back would you rather
somebody come to your house with a knife
or would you rather somebody come to
your house and prove to you irrevocably
that you're not good you're not a good
person
you're a piece of shit i think i
i might choose the knife
because because if somebody if somebody
came to me with proof
and showed me that i was a bad person i
don't know how i'd recover
from that i mean the scene with alfred
molina was
devastating like he knew it was coming
it was a matter of time
he didn't know exactly what was coming
but he was
broken and just
opened the door um yeah
which leads me another question here
from milo uh asks for carrie what was it
like reuniting with alfred molina
it was so nice he's just heaven
he's just the best um so i was so happy
just to
be around him and hang out with him but
to act with him and this
it was so surprising what he did with
that part um
and it was really one of you know it was
it was genuinely unnerving and
frightening
um his kind of open pain and his
vulnerability and like how much he
ferociously kind of despised himself you
know it was really
um but yeah he was just brilliant and i
just loved
loved getting to hang out with him and
he was only there for
i don't know a day but heaven
it was an amazing scene um
let's see so many more questions um
some of this we've talked about uh this
was easily the best movie of the year
uh is one comment uh
one of my favorite movies of the year uh
this one says this is one of my favorite
movies of the year but it has such a
polarizing ending i have seen people
praise and decry it for a variety of
reasons
do you think it was even possible to end
a movie like this in any way that would
satisfy
everyone
um no i don't think so it's such a
personal thing
i mean it's such a um
complicated and difficult thing that i
don't think you can
you can only really focus on the thing
that that feels
true to you and i think um
yeah i think really of course it's not
possible for everyone's experience
or uh yeah everyone's sort of wishes i
think to be reflected and that's
something i think quite early on
i had to sort of come to terms with and
and also to say that people
you know you can
not like something and or you can love
something
but that doesn't necessarily make it
right or wrong or good or bad
i think we're it's okay to just not like
something
and yeah but that's obviously hard when
it's something you've made and
everyone universally to say you're a
really uh
sexy genius who deserves and a tiara
yeah well one of the amazing things
about that ending i felt was
like as stuck as cassie is in her life
and stuck in the past and everything
like carrie you're you're like a person
of incredible
agency in this film like you are even
though the audience doesn't know what's
going on at the beginning is it unfold
like you are constantly in motion
pursuing justice vengeance whatever
you're
you're on a mission and you're
constantly moving
and taking action and you're not
paralyzed or from doing that from doing
everything that you do
so when your character is killed it's
this is such a
i mean it's like oh my god like the
person driving this has been killed it's
so
devastating at that moment um it's
it's i can't think of another film like
that i mean it's
i love the ending but i was like so
surprised by it because she was the
engine of
everything that was happening um
yeah it just felt it always felt very
i think emerald's probably being modest
in that of course we had incredibly
supportive producers but i think there's
always going to be people around
uh who will try and
um persuade you perhaps to soften things
or to make things a little bit
more palatable or to perhaps you know
and i think that you know it takes a
real
singular vision and real strength of
character to be able to
stand absolutely by your decision
and um and i and i and i 100
supported that i think it's the you know
it's so tragically just the truth of
those situations we've seen that this
year more than
any you know time in recent history that
women
you know the statistics again you know
in violence against women this last year
has just been horrific
um and so that it it did feel like the
only honest
um ending to the film and i think you
know what i
i think emerald did so brilliantly with
this is create something that is fun and
is stylish and
is something a world you want to be a
part of but every single character in
this film
feels like a real person you know
they've all the writing is so rich
they're
they've got they've all got something to
play it's white attracted such great
actors
um who came in for a day like connie and
alfred and
molly and i think it was just you know
there's
there's a real real truth to the way
that everybody in an honesty the way
that people are
the actors work in this and the story
you know goes so the ending had to live
up to that
um let's see i've got another couple
questions here one is somebody asked
about knight of the hunter
and your references to that in the film
could you talk about how
when that film sort of came into your
consciousness as you were working on
this and
um i think it's just
it is my favorite film i think it's
perfect and
i suppose
it shares maybe a few things
thematically with with
promising a woman but um
there are a few things practically we
needed something for her parents to be
watching and i think that's speech
about um women and how
sort of um
sort of sexy and repulsive he finds them
was just such a brilliant is just such a
brilliant moment and a lovely sort of
thing for them to be watching and then
um the song the lullaby is just so
beautiful and moving but really for me
it's the perfect example of a movie that
is as allegorical
as it is you know specific
and that's why it
feels so powerful certainly to me it
sort of
hits me in a very sort of um
kind of primal place i suppose and
really with promising a woman i wanted
it always wanted it to feel like that
like a
like a bible story or an allegory or a
you know a greek tragedy this all
i realized that was incredibly sort of
overblown but
i think things do things don't need to
feel 100
real for them to feel 100 real i guess
uh a question from somebody named
kimberly asking in cassie's journal do
the red and black hash marks indicate
what she did to the men
i assumed that the red marks meant she
had killed them but maybe just that she
drew blood
we're never going to say
never it's the secret it is a secret i'm
afraid
okay uh one person asks
um uh it's driving me crazy what song
was playing when cassie hit the truck
i recognized the instrumental music but
can't put my finger on it um
it is from tristan and is older it's
wagner's um liebenstadt
um and then somebody asked have you in
terms of audience reactions to the film
which
may be hard to answer since outside of
sundance we're not seeing it with
audiences but have you heard or
experienced different reactions from men
and women to watching the film
um i think it actually hasn't been that
gendered
certainly in my experience but as you
say it's been quite hard to gauge
because we're not physically kind of
seeing anything but
but in my experience with some people
kind of talking just talking to people
it seemed that
certainly people feel strongly about it
one way or another but
it's often surprising it's it's often
surprising
which side you know they fall
and then somebody i can't find it
somebody asked a question about casting
the guys in the film
the the nice guys who turned out not to
be so nice how did you
approach that casting like what were you
looking for
from those actors when you were in the
casting process
i think i was just looking for the
people that we all really like and trust
so really you know good looking guys um
people who have been on shows or on
movies that we feel really like
fondly towards i think you know it's
the the p the stuff is complicated
because
it isn't just villains that do it it's
your
close friend or your brother or you know
the
kind of prom king or the like nerdy guy
who never would hurt a fly but might
like maybe take advantage so
it had to be like the kind of guys that
um that do this stuff which is sort of
funny
nice normal good-looking guys yeah
oh burnham i did not see that coming
i mean i was wondering how things were
going to play out with him but that was
but that's another interesting one
because lots of people feel like
she should have given her another chance
there's there's another thing about this
you know like uh what you know what
stage
does she you know has should she have
forgiven him
it's i mean i not have no answer well i
mean i do but i
won't but like lots of people felt she
just should have forgiven him
and married him
very tall and
delightful so yeah
um okay so i think we have time for one
more question this comes from someone
named mito
uh who identifies i'm gonna preface by
saying he identifies as a male filmmaker
and he says
i'd love to ask you both about your
thoughts on male screenwriters directors
i'm one making women-centric films the
project
the projects i'm working on each have a
woman character at their core
but i'm aware that i'm walking a
tightrope developing and pitching these
projects
i mean i'm sure we both have i mean i i
think
absolutely of course
write right film with any protagonist
that you want i think as
long as you know
i i don't see i think it would it was a
real like
lack of empathy if people couldn't um
write female characters or male
characters and
um yeah as long as as long as the film
isn't just
lots of ladies taking their clothes off
um
and then i will of course i think
should people and even then like there
might be a reason for that
so i don't know but i um no of course
right what you want to write but you
know but it's just that thing of like
bearing in mind that there are a ton of
writers writing amazing stuff and so
it's just
you know if you really believe the thing
that you're writing is amazing then
absolutely you always write it some of
the best characters ever have been
written by
opposite genders like well i mean that's
my feeling kerry
what do you what do you think yeah i
mean we wouldn't have
fargo if the current brothers hadn't
written that for francis mcdormand so
like crack on make more great parts for
women
yes
okay and actually this is the truly last
question uh
somebody anonymous writes i have to know
did bo burnham
really drink carrie's spit oh yeah
yeah like a number of times and he knew
it as well
it was it was it was weird but yeah he
did
it wasn't weird he's just an incredibly
dedicated actor
and i think i think he did it once by
accident and once like mildly on purpose
then got a taste for it
no he was dedicated and there's a great
there are some great outtakes of
when you know kerry really spat quite a
lot into his coffee and he'd gotten
quite but
you know he couldn't do it now of course
kovitch
yeah right definitely
when were you actually in production
what were your dates
um it was march
oh no it was april may 2019 okay
23 days wow wow
amazing punishing punishing
impossible without someone as brilliant
as scary and everyone else but you know
wow my internet cut out do you say 23
days
yeah yeah not to blow smoke but also
emerald was three weeks away from having
a baby when we wrapped so she was
like
huge
you've never known you would never have
known she was so cool
no i mean yeah he had a bump um well i
want to thank you both
for um for the film first and foremost
and for being here and having this
conversation i could
we have lots more questions i'm not
going to be able to get to but i just
thank you so much for taking the time to
talk to film independent and um
we will continue to spread the word
about the film and and huge congrats
it's it's
one of the best films of the year
without a doubt and one that i know will
stick in my mind and memory for a long
time and
i cannot wait to watch it with my wife
which i i watch it by myself the first
time but i'm
i want to watch it with other people and
have that experience
oh thank you so much thank you for
having us
yeah thank you very much thank you
carrie all right we'll see you guys soon
thanks again